make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and for
the first time in recorded marvel
history wolverine meets mad jim jaspers
and this is hugely exciting i am so
excited about this because it's just a
cool moment right it's just a cool part
of this story but before we get into
that we pick up with the next part of
our battle right of our exo swords event
and this picks up in the holy republic
of faye which leads to the floating
kingdom of romo regina
kind of passing through a portal to
access another location and what we have
here
is ileana rasputin facing off against
hoggerpog right one of the forces of a
rocko kind of a weird name
it's a little bit interesting guys
basically like a giant crocodile thing
but
the funny thing about this is that with
iliana rasputin she is prodigious with a
sword not to mention when you add in the
various magical effects that come with
the soul sword along with her ability to
use magic as well
this fight is a non-starter right it's
done the problem
is this is not a sword fight this is an
arm wrestling contest
saturnine changes it on a whim she's
like nope uh this is a contest of
arms so hands clasped shoulder square
elbows in the pocket
pin to win and it's like arm wrestling
seriously and of course
pogba pog decimates ileana rasputin now
one of the things we're going to find
out here
and one of the things you're going to
see over the course of this is that
there's something pretty sketchy going
on right and we kind of talked about
that in a previous video
some things pretty it seemed pretty
sketchy but with pogba pogba victor here
the score now stands at a rocco three
kakoa one and so at that point we switch
over to a place called the blight spoke
and this is a wholly new environment
that was created by jonathan hickman in
this story the funny thing about this
is that this is a an interesting
scenario an interesting situation
historically speaking when it comes to
alternate realities in marvel comics
every universe that dies is reborn again
and it really kind of follows the
function that that universe is destroyed
and then kind of coalesced into a new
universe so it doesn't really matter how
it happens so if you were to take
like the main marvel universe right we
were to say this universe reaches its
inevitable heat death which is to say
the point at which it's going to die you
have the big bang where everything
expands outwards and you have the big
crunch where it all condenses back into
a singular you know singular point of
energy and it explodes in a big bang
and is reborn again but say for example
somebody like
jean grey as the dark phoenix lost her
mind and wiped out the whole universe
the universe would be singularly
destroyed and that would be the end of
it right that would be the end of that
universe
in previous years it was always assumed
that the end of that of that universe
would lead to it being reborn right it
would just somehow come back into
existence again what jonathan hickman
does is he says
nope that doesn't happen when a universe
is destroyed prematurely in that form it
goes to a place called the blight spoke
and the blight spoke is
is kind of a composite of just dead
realities right where they all just sort
of coalesce
into a singular landmass right so if you
were to say like the united states for
example
is a combination of dead realities then
like chicago is like
is like an alternate reality and new
york is an alternate reality and
california is an alternate reality right
like all these cities and all these
states are all just
alternate realities but they all kind of
share this this sort of energy that's
called the blight energy in the sense
that when a person's there
it quite literally drains off your life
essence right
it'll kill you over time that's the
reason why wolverine and the summoner
are brought here is because they are
they have a healing factor and they are
for the most part
indestructible that's kind of what
they're referred to but the reason why
this fight is so intriguing is because
when wolverine finally calls out
summoner and someone who responds to him
that what they end up doing is literally
falling through different realities and
as they fall through these different
realities they experience a kind of
reality shift so
in one universe they're just covered in
bugs right bugs basically took over this
entire universe and killed everything in
existence in another universe it's more
old school in another universe
you have a scenario where summoner is
actually kind of like an old man logan
type character there's one universe
where they're all kind of futuristic
right there's
it all kind of bounces and it changes
around one where like the many angled
ones conquered everything right one with
their chess pieces
it's just any possibility that exists
there's a universe for it and that's one
of the things that marvel never really
explored and in fact a lot of you guys
had a really cool idea for a video
uh that i will make that i'm actually
gonna make on that not really a video
per se but a comic book series then i'm
actually gonna i'm gonna talk about that
i'm gonna make a separate video on that
because i think it's really really cool
but at the end of the day when it's all
said and done uh wolverine manages to
get the upper hand on summoner
stabs him through the eye and kills him
and he loses and the reason why is
because
saturning comes along and says nope this
was a fight to the death
summoner fought to the death you fought
to stay alive
therefore you lose as you guys can tell
the odds are basically stacked against
krakowa that what it looks like is
happening is saturnine is
basically cooking the books in order to
ensure that krakowa loses now
from that point we switch over to the
crooked market and this is basically
just
the bar that's run by jim jasper's where
you have wolverine and you have storms
sharing a drink and what we end up
getting is basically a card presented to
them whereby
it's a drinking contest right they both
have to drink and whoever lasts the
longest
ends up winning the benefit of this is
that it's a guaranteed victory for kokoa
it's a guaranteed point but the funny
thing is that jim jasper's kind of has
this quick little conversation with
wolverine where he talks about the
blightness is bloody magnificent is what
he refers to it as right this drink
called the blightness is one of the most
exquisite things that either of them
will ever put into their mouths now
i can't reiterate this enough this is
the first time this ever happened right
um to me
let me tell you something man to me this
is exciting this is hugely exciting jim
jasper's
meeting the x-men for the very first
time this only matters if you're a fan
of jim jasper's but this guy could end
these guys like that
and in fact jim jaspers will actually
show off his powers here in a little
while here and i think
uh in the next video that we'll do he'll
show off his powers you'll see
what the kind of stuff jim jaspers is
capable of but one of the fan theories
and this is a genius idea that one of
you guys came out with
one of the theories that you guys came
out with on discord is you said what if
jim jaspers is actually the one
controlling everything
and saturnine is just doing what he
tells her to he's the one who's actually
in control of this and saturnine is a
servant to him
what if that's the case and i was like
that's kind of nuts because that's
entirely possible right i mean this guy
is a universal shaper he can control
any space that he's in it's ridiculous
how powerful jim jaspers is and a whim
he could turn these guys into ants right
wolverine and and storm
he could break them down and just turn
them into stone he could turn them into
each other but he could turn wolverine
in a storm and storm into wolverine he
could he could do any number of things
right this guy there's no limit whatever
it is he can imagine doing it becomes
reality right that's just how powerful
this guy is but what we also end up
finding out is that as they're drinking
this
wolverine starts to get drunk and that
doesn't happen because remember
wolverine's healing factor keeps them
from getting drunk now that is alcohol
in the main marvel universe this
may be an entirely different breed or at
least that seemed to be the case until
we finally
find out the horseman death who's
currently a part of the uh of the iraqi
forces working for
rocco he presents an artifact to jim
jasper's and we end up finding out what
death did
is he bribed jaspers to poison the drink
of wolverine and storm
to make them drunk not only that as they
start to get drunk that it picks up with
the next battle between the forces of
krakow i'm sorry the forces of morocco
that where kakoa got a battle amongst
themselves a rocko got a battle amongst
themselves
as well and the logic behind this
according to saturnine is that they all
originated from a singular landmass the
landmass of okara and so in essence it
is basically
groups that are part of the same
community all fighting against each
other right that's the stance of
saturnine and so for oracle to fight
krakowa they're basically fighting
themselves and that's why these these
kind of
battles among the kirkhoen and oracle
forces as part of this tournament is
taking place but what you end up getting
here is basically solemn
facing off against the horsemen of war
and this is a personal vendetta because
remember
solemn had killed the husband of
horseman war at some point in the past
but the caveat to this is that if you
guys recall
solemn and wolverine met each other and
a bargain was struck between the two
that they were both tasked with tracking
down the muramasa blade and that solomon
got his hands on both
and so he was only going to relinquish
his blade to wolverine if wolverine
would strike a deal and that deal
is brought into full fray when wolverine
is teleported away from the storm and
brought to this conflict drunk is a
skunk and
the bargain that was struck was that at
some point in time at a time of his
choosing
wolverine would fight in the place of
solemn and he's calling in this he's
calling in this favor now the funny
thing about this
is that it doesn't really seem to matter
that in reality here that because solemn
has adamantium's skin that wouldn't
really make any difference war
would not be able to defeat solomon so
something else seems to be going on here
what that is we don't fully know but
with wolverine being here and being
absolutely drunk
he also reveals that he's the one who
killed summoner summoner of course being
the son
of horseman war and so solemn killed her
husband wolverine killed her son the
horseman war is pissed and so because of
that
she starts losing it right starts going
off on wolverine full blast now
wolverine real you know
kind of experiences this this cut and
one of the things that saturnine
really a comment she really kind of
makes here and what's really interesting
is she draws a great a great concept
here she says you've become
reckless you've become reckless in the
face of the fact that one you can heal
from anything
and two the resurrection protocols can
always bring you back
you've become exceedingly cavalier you
don't know what it's like to fight to
the death anymore and and that really i
would i would say is a great analysis
that's the winning edge the x-men have
lost since they've been on krakowa
the funny thing is that the idea of
creating cocoa or bringing all the x-men
to that island in the first place by
xavier was to create a place where the
x-men and really the mutant population
could have their own government could
have their own their own island mass but
in the more macro scale right the much
larger scale here it was all done from
what we saw during house and powers of
10 right half of x powers of 10
uh that we basically saw this situation
where a war was going to happen at some
point in the future and so all of it
seemed to have been done for the purpose
of making the x-men stronger and even
apocalypse himself in the early days
when his
family and his horsemen ended up inside
oracle he made the promise to his wife
that he would make the world stronger
but in giving people the ability to
always come back from the dead you make
them weaker because suddenly
none of the battles that they're in
matter because their philosophy is well
no matter what happens i'll always come
back so even if it's not a conscious
thought
it's a subconscious thought even if i
die i'll come back and so they lose the
edge that they get when they play for
keeps and that's the point that
saturnine makes that you've become
reckless you've become complacent the
wolverine of yesteryear would have
slaughtered war right would have
absolutely ripped through war this
battle would have been a non-starter the
horseman war would have died
so fast but over the over the years his
healing factor all those things playing
in
wolverine's lost his edge and it's
really kind of a way of jonathan hickman
criticizing the publishing history of
marvel and saying you've taken away from
the
ferocity of one of the most ferocious
characters in marvel because over time
he always just comes back and so what we
end up finding out is the caveat from
having that drink at jim jasper's bar as
part of the bargain that was struck
between jim jasper's and the horsemen of
death
is that when they were poisoned it took
their powers wolverine has lost his
healing factor he doesn't have the
ability to come back from the dead and
so you end up having
uh war who manages to pin him get the
upper hand and then go for the killing
blow but of course she cannot actually
kill him because he has an adamantium
skeleton but in the end
the win is given directly to horseman
war because wolverine cuts off her hand
but
the problem with wolverine cutting off
her hand is that's not a killing blow
because horseman war got the killing
blow even though wolverine didn't
actually die
the victory goes to a rocco now i'm of
the mind that if saturnine were playing
fair the victory would have gone to
wolverine because
he can't be killed and because he can't
be killed there's no way it can be a
fight to the death right so that would
have been the end of it but again it's
one of these things
where it looks like saturnine is
intentionally cheating in order to make
sure
the forces of morocco come out on top
and if that's true then the question
becomes
why but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you